welcome back if you were injured in an
accident you're going to want personal
attention from your attorney
and that's where our next guest comes
into play let's welcome attorney
jonathan weber to the show jonathan
welcome tell us what makes your firm
different from the others well what
makes me different
is that i can give my clients personal
attention they're really not gonna get
if they try to uh get out with another
bigger law firm where they're just gonna
hit a wall of
paralegals assistance people answering
the phone that actually kind of
barricade
the attorney away from the client which
is backwards of how it should be
my clients can get a hold of me anytime
they want they call me directly
i call them directly to give them status
on how things are going so
i've been practicing since 2015 that way
been in practicing
as an attorney total since 2000 and i
love practicing this way i can really
give my clients the personal service i
think they deserve
i think you touched on it there you're
available availability to your clients
you're available 24 7. i'm not going
through a bunch of other people if i
need you i'm talking directly to you
you've got that right and my clients can
call me on the weekends they can text or
email me before or after hours
if they need me to come out to see them
they can have me arranged to do that now
other attorneys will advertise that they
do that but they're not going to drive
out and actually see their clients uh
they've got a big firm they they've got
to
handle and be with i am my own law firm
i'm a solo attorney so i actually do get
out to see my clients whenever they need
me to
we got about 60 seconds i want to talk
about specific incidents and how people
should handle them
what is the first thing we should do if
we're in a car accident
if you're a car accident make sure
you're okay and the people that are in
your car are okay
second make sure that you're documenting
everything taking pictures
don't be afraid to call police uh so
they'll document whose
fault they may be able to cite the other
person and that way that helps me take a
couple of steps ahead
to make sure i can prove fault and get
your injury claims started for you
properly
all right i think a lot of people now
outside more if someone is let's say
they're walking a dog and they're bitten
by a dog
what should they do then absolutely if
you can get a picture of that dog
second document everything where it
happened when it happened
and then you may even want to be able to
call animal control and file a complaint
and see if there's been a history with
that dog
especially if it's a dangerous breed and
that gets into statutorily nevada
what types of breeds are dangerous and
whether it was out of control of the
owner
so all those things are really super
important to document right after it
happens
right less than 30 seconds slip and fall
someone's involved in a slip and fall
what should they do
it's tough nevada those are real tough
cases to prove because you have to have
either actual or constructive notice
that there was a danger that the
business owner should have known about
or did know about before you got there
you actually have to be able to prove
that if there were cones set up if there
weren't if an employee says oh yeah i
knew there was
water or there was a substance there you
could have slipped on but i just didn't
get there in time
and that doesn't happen very often so
those are tough to prove right out of
the gates
well jonathan we truly appreciate your
time thank you so much for joining us
today
thank you sir get in touch with the
experts at weber law firm by giving them
a call at 702-538-5761
and find them online at weber
dashlawfirm.com for more mercedes